okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i see there are all kinds of
questions uh stored up here
sent in um
all right let's see where should we
start let's start with one from erin
here
can you explain rasterization
does the human visual system use a
molecular scale version of rasterization
okay well let's talk about representing
pictures on computers and elsewhere so
there are two fundamental ways that
computers tend to represent images
so-called bitmap graphics
and vector graphics so let me try to
explain that what what that's about
so one thing you can do like on your
computer screen
your computer screen consists of an
array of millions of pixels millions of
individual places where there's a red
green and blue
dot basically they're usually
rectangular actually if you look at them
under magnifying glass or these days
almost a microscope you can see they're
usually these little rectangular uh
regions that light up where where in
each little little place on the screen
there's a little region that lights up
red original lights are green a region
that lights up blue those make primary
colors and that um and where in places
where your screen looks white all three
of those are lit up
um so
one way to represent an image
is just to decide which of those pixels
you'll light up on a screen
um
and
that
uh that's a so-called bitmap image the
reason it's called a bitmap image
is because
in the past people would say let's
construct
what
uh
let's let's
say what are we going to display on our
computer screen
um they would assemble that in the
memory of the computer so in the memory
of the computer there will be a bunch of
memory locations and they're kind of
laid out linearly actually but but um
that and what one's saying is in the
memory of the computer say this
this place is going to be a one let's
say black another place is going to be
zero it's white let's say
and you're going to lay them out in a in
a sort of map
in the memory of the computer and then
you're going to
uh
it's kind of an abuse of of names but in
the end you're going to have um uh this
these bits on the screen are going to be
laid out in this map in memory
and there are things like um uh bit
blitting which was some
kind of an operation where you would do
things where
you are in the memory of the computer
you are combining let's say two
different pieces of image in a certain
way which will then be bitmapped
it is the usual terminology onto the
screen so there's a place in computer
memory and then that's what that what
you see on the screen is kind of a
mirror of what's in computer memory and
that's still the way things tend to work
in computers at a very low level but
that's not something you typically have
to know about in using the computer but
so one way of representing an image is
as a bitmap that is something where
you've turned the image into a whole
bunch of of little little square pixels
and each for each pixel you say what its
color is that's way number one way
number two is so-called vector graphics
where um or what one might call symbolic
graphics that will be the kind of the
term in and more and more from language
um
well what you do is you say
there's a line
from this coordinate position to that
coordinate position there's a circle
there's a there's this thing there's
that thing there these objects that you
can describe in a sense geometrically um
which go across many different pixels on
the screen um but uh they are um they're
described in geometrical terms
okay so
in the
history of these things
a place where it was really important to
describe things are really useful to
describe things geometrically was in
fonts
so if you have a letter a for example
you can imagine drawing that letter a if
you draw it very small you wouldn't
notice that you all you're determining
in the in the letter a is which pixels
were were black in the letter a but if
you blow that letter a up and you make
it a 100 point font one one point is one
well it's a little bit complicated but
when it's printed a so-called printer's
point is one seventy second of an inch
um so a when you say
a font size such and such let's say you
say 12 point font
what that means is that
the
i guess it's the x height the height of
a lowercase x
is equal to 12 printers points or 12 70
seconds of an inch
um and so when you know when you say 36
point type that's pretty big headline
type type that means 36 point type is
half an inch high that means that the x
in that font is half an inch high it's
it's a rather confusing thing in fonts
there are measurements that are based on
uh
actual letters of the of the english
alphabet so for example when you measure
spacing or you'll often call it
say it's in terms of ms
usually spelled em and that is literally
the width of the character the m
character in that font
and obviously different fonts have
different
uh the letters are different widths and
so on just to say something about fonts
the uh there are really uh several
attributes of fonts that are very very
clear one of them is uh serif versus
sans serif that is when you have a
letter like an i for example do is the i
just a vertical bar
or does the i have these things at the
top which are sort of horizontal pieces
that come out that are kind of um well
so-called serifs they're things that
stick out of the letters originally if
you go back and you look at you know
inscriptions in ancient rome for example
you'll find a lot of serif letters that
was a convenient thing for stonemasons
when they were carving out these letters
on on pieces of stone that was a
convenient elegant thing for them to do
it's actually remarkable to me when you
look at those inscriptions from ancient
rome how similar the kind of the forms
of letters look to the forms that we use
today so over more than 2 000 years
forms of letters haven't changed very
much
in i was a was a much more recent thing
of like 100 years ago uh at a time when
a lot of kind of design uh sensibility
went from being uh rather sort of
classical and with lots of curves and
and detail and so on to
more so-called modern which was more
sort of geometrical you know kind of
structures that were houses that were
kind of like just boxes rather than
having all kinds of elaborate moldings
and and um uh elaborate kind of
decoration on them that was a a thing of
a bit more than 100 years ago and at
that same time also people were started
being interested in fonts that were
sans-serif sans meaning french without
uh serifs um so fonts where the letter i
would just be this vertical thing
without sort of things hanging out at
the top and bottom
and usually uh there are different
purposes for which people use i mean
sans serif fonts are often used for
headings um and sometimes used for
captions and in images and so on serif
fonts tend to be used for more kind of
main text of things there are a bunch of
pieces of evidence that the human
physical system finds it easier to read
things when you're reading kind of
narrative text it finds it easier to
read when it has kind of a clue of these
extra serifs and maybe sans serif is
better for just the the few characters
that you might see in a caption or
something like this
um
and uh so that's that's one sort of
attribute of fonts is the serifs versus
no serifs um another attribute of fonts
is uh monospaced or proportionally
spaced what does that mean when people
had typewriters um any character any
letter um an an l for example is a
pretty narrow letter lowercase l or
lowercase i those are um
sort of naturally rather narrow letters
but a lowercase m for example is a big
long letter
um and so but a typewriter it just used
a fixed amount of space
for each letter so it had a a um mono
spaced single spacing uh kind of uh way
of doing things so when you make a
monos-based font um you have to every
letter has to have a certain form in
that font and so for example letter i
you tend to have to have these great big
serifs you know an i is just this
vertical piece and then these great big
horizontal pieces at the top and bottom
to kind of widen out the eye so it
doesn't so it looks okay um even though
the font is mono spaced is is everything
is equally spaced
proportionally spaced
is kind of the the case where uh where
the letter i is very narrow and and uh
usually it's it's more elegant to read a
proportionally spaced um
uh kind of font
and uh monospace is sometimes it's the
old-fashioned typewriter form it's also
early computer displays uh we're all
kind of mono-based fonts and sometimes
when it's like oh i want it to look like
computer input or output one uses kind
of a monospace font for that
um the thing that uh
there are many things in um
uh in
uh uh by the way i should say that when
people were making were doing early
moveable type
so i mean back in in uh when was the
1400s or something am i right fourteen
fifteen hundreds fourteen hundreds um
the
the the sort of the big invention in
terms of printing presses was this idea
that instead of just having something
where you would if you wanted to print
something like you do with you know
potato prince or something you carve out
the pattern on the potato you stick it
in some ink and you put it on a piece of
paper that's a way of you know given a
particular sort of carving you will um
uh you'll always print the same thing or
for example if you had uh uh some seal
um that was going to be a thing where
you would make you know an impression
with the with you know the seal that was
on the ring on your finger or something
that would be the thing that says yes
it's me signing my name and that was
something people could do
um even before there was widespread
literacy even before you know the the
the kings and queens of ancient times or
something uh even though they couldn't
read you know they couldn't read and
write
that was delegated to other people just
as often people delegate programming to
other people today
um but uh you know those days what would
often happen is they would have this
this ring on their finger which would
have some particular design on it and
they would uh indicate yes you know they
really agreed with some some big
document that was put in front of them
by pressing that ring into a piece of
hot wax that would keep the impression
of whatever it was on on that ring and
you kind of knew
you know the queen did it herself type
thing because um it was uh because you
know that ring is is only to be found on
her finger so to speak
um so in any case the the the sort of
the big idea of early printing was was
the idea of of type that wasn't just a
fixed thing that you carved out it was
something where you would just have a
lot of little pieces of of individual
letters
usually made of lead
um because that was a convenient soft
metal
and so like when i was a kid for example
i used to use these things um you would
have uh you know a case of letters we
would have the lowercase
and we would have the uppercase and they
would be um the case of letters would be
this this wooden box
with a bunch of e's a bunch of t's a
bunch of w's a bunch of z's and they
always have little those little the the
little areas for the different letters
would always be different sizes so like
there'd be more e's and t's then there
were w's and z's just because in a
typical thing that you're going to type
set there would be more copies of there
would be more words that have ease on
them and then have z's in them so anyway
you you do this and the way it worked
was you would you would have a a metal
thing that you made the type and you put
each letter and you put it actually in
upside down and then to make spacing to
the next row of letters beneath it you
would put a little piece of lead
and that's where the term leading that
uh you see in in modern uh you know font
layout and modern layouts leading is the
amount of lead literally little pieces
of lead that you would put in between
one row of type and the next row of type
so that was kind of the approach to sort
of type setting was you pick the
individual letters out of the the upper
or lower case of letters and you put
them in this thing that you were forming
to make this uh
letterpress um you you just make this uh
this thing and when you were finished
typesetting that particular page you
would uh break apart all the type and
put all the letters back in there in
their appropriate places and then you
reuse them again for the next page you
want to to typeset
so by the way just in sort of the
history of typesetting just to fill that
in just uh people find that interesting
the the big thing that was invented was
photolithography
so the idea was that instead of having a
um
instead of
individually taking those letters made
of lead and by hands and putting each
letter off to another one what you would
do is essentially have a photographic
image of
the
page that you wanted to produce
and then you would use that photographic
image to etch away a plate
um that was a metal plate
and you would etch it away in such a way
that the places where for example there
was white
on the um
on the original photographic image would
be etched away in the places where they
were black would be still sort of
sticking out
and then in order to print something a
bit like potato prince or something you
take that plate and you would put it
you'd have a typical roller but put ink
on it and then you would take that plate
and put a sheet of paper next to it and
then you've got it printed and so this
idea of taking a photographic image and
etching away a plate so how did the
actual action work uh how does it work
today
i think what happens is very similar to
the way that a microprocessor chip is
made that is you have this this plate is
made of metal and i i think you use some
uh
uh
use something where the the material
is light sensitive i think with
ultraviolet light and where ultraviolet
light has fallen on this piece of metal
it can be etched away with acid and
where where it hasn't fallen it can't be
etched away and so it hasn't fallen
you'll have kind of a mountain there and
that's the thing that will get the black
ink on it or whatever um and that's
that's how you'd end up printing that
that's how you print that piece and so
that's that's the typical way that
printing is done now now the way when
printing is done
um it's a little bit like the way it
works on your screen in the sense that
you'll have red green blue except that
for printing so the primary colors for
light are red green blue the primary
colors for printing so for for light
what is relevant is
the emission of light and that we our
eyes are sensitive to combinations of
red green and blue uh for determining
what we perceive as color but when you
are dealing with something printed what
matters is what light is absorbed by the
page and so what you want are the
complementary colors to red green and
blue which are cyan magenta and yellow
and so when you print things
um you are using little dots of ink that
are cyan magenta yellow and black
um so it's cmyk is the usual sort of
system
for color that's used for printing and
if you look under magnifying glass
you'll find
that
essentially any printed page
color printed page will have these
little rosettes of colors and what's
happened is that uh it's it's kind of
like the screen of your computer the
screen of your computer
has arranged red green blue dots all in
a rectangular array
in in the case of printing it's again
the yellow cyan magenta yellow
black are all dots
but there's sort of a trick that's used
instead of instead of arranging those
dots all in a kind of regular grid
the dots for different colors are
arranged in grids at different angles
and the reason that's done is to prevent
places where sort of all the dots would
line up and you'd see some weird
line and the you you'd perceive a weird
line even though you can't see the
individual dots when you have enough of
them lined up you would generate a line
on the page
um
and so typically those are i think um
uh i forget the angles but there are
there are angles that that have the
property that they don't
end up their their their their sort of
irregular kinds of numbers that end up
not sort of lining up in such a way that
lots of dots end up on top of each other
but so that's what you'll see in in sort
of four color printing so-called
four-color printing i mean just to say
something else about that technology
when um uh usually sort of generic it's
a picture in color it will be printed in
four colors uh see outside magenta
yellow and black
um and and that's done with it with an
actual printing press it's done by
having four separate passes um where for
each color uh you know where you first
of all you have a plate that is the
yellow plate the i don't know what order
it's standing but but you know cyan
magenta yellow black
um and those are separate plates and
separate passes in the printing process
but you can also add extra colors so
let's say that you have a you're trying
to make this dramatic brochure or
something and your company's color is
purple um and you really want a big
solid blob of purple in your brochure um
then you can add what's i think the
printing industry called the spot color
where you are adding a kind of in
addition to the cyan magenta yellow and
black you'll have an additional
place where there's a whole
printing a whole piece of the printing
process that's just using
a purple ink for example and so it's
pretty common to have six color printing
where you have two additional colors
that are used for kind of your your sort
of highlight colors of something where
that particular color is going to be
used a lot in a particular book or
whatever else
so okay back to
back to how um
i was talking about how fonts are made
and so one of the questions is when you
form
if you have a letter a for example you
want to expand it you want to make it 72
point type so it's a you know an inch
high type thing
um the uh you're going to want it to be
the case that that you have sort of the
same specification of the a
and as you make it bigger and bigger it
doesn't look it doesn't look bad it
still looks good by the way i should
just a slightly technical point the this
thing where i said a princess point is
one seventy second of an inch and you
can measure 12 point type blah blah blah
um needless to say in the actual
development of technology things got
more complicated than that um because
people decided that screens
what they thought was a 12-point font
when it was printed should look a little
different on the screen and so
uh well mac and windows have different
conventions for how big an actual point
is an actual printer's point an actual
172nd of an inch when it was printed how
big that should appear on the screen and
boy is that a mess i mean we're still
cleaning up that mess
in wolfram language today you know
decades after that mess was originally
created and that means that things when
you have something which looks a
particular way on the screen and then
you print it
pretty much every word processor has
cheats in it that say well make it
eighty percent of the size when you
actually print it and that sort of
messes around with what it really means
to be a 12 point font and things like
that and what a single printer's point
what the actual size of that is on a
screen and whether if you measured it
with a ruler it would be that size and
usually it wouldn't because of because
of these various cheats that are put in
to make it visually appropriate because
something that looks the right size on
the screen if you printed it it sort of
quotes the same size would look too big
on a piece of paper and so on
okay anyway back to fonts
so one of the issues is
when you you have a letter a or
something like that is you know you make
it in like 12 point font if you look on
your computer screen you'll see that
it's just made of pixels it's it's got
all those jagged edges but if you want
to take that same sort of specification
of the shape of an a and blow it up
really big you don't want to see jagged
edges there you want to see nice smooth
curves
so one of the big innovations uh which
is actually sort of a key innovation of
postscript the page description language
uh that was in the early 1980s i guess
this happened um the um uh was this idea
of describing uh fonts i mean this is
actually
preceded postscript but that was the
place where it really got kind of uh um
you know widely used um
uh to describe fonts
by kind of smooth curves so you say
oh this letter o for example it's got an
actual circle in it um it's not just oh
the pixels are placed here and here and
here it's the thing is specified by two
concentric circles let's say for letter
o
and and so that's what a typical vector
graphics approach would be
is to say you'll specify it by those
geometric primitives rather than
specifying where the pixels are when
it's finally rendered on screen
it's going to be converted from vector
graphics to bitmap graphics to actually
display on the screen
and so in the case of fonts
um the uh the typical way that they're
represented so the question is what kind
of curves do you need to make a letter a
and um
uh back in the day oh people um
oh gosh
famous font person
oh my gosh um
there's a famous book called oh dura
albectura wrote a book on the on the on
the just formation of letters or
something sort of famous artist and um
uh described kind of how you make a
letter like a letter a oh is it really a
circle a letter whatever is it you know
what are those curves
okay so the big the big sort of
trick
of making these fonts
is it turns out
you can use cubic curves
so for example a um a circle
is an example of a curve that
mathematically is the curve that is x
squared plus y squared equals one let's
say that makes a circle
if you
start talking about curves with cubes
instead of squares in them you get a
slightly a bigger range of different
possible curves they can wiggle in
different ways um it turns out that
using just cubic curves is sufficient to
make things that look to us like oh
that's a nice curve appropriate for a
letter
so
the the essentially all the letters
formed in all the fonts are made from uh
well sometimes called cubic splines
sometimes so-called bezier curves um
these are very similar kinds of things
um that are what's used to define these
kinds of curves now the way those get
defined is they they you can typically
have what you you have is when you have
a straight line you just define a line
by two points
it's the you know you just join those
you you take pieces of string you pull
it at the two ends it'll make a line the
shortest path between two points is a
line
okay you can make a bezier curve by
saying that in addition to saying that
the curve has to go through certain
points you also define that the slope of
the curve has to be this or that at this
or that point
and that the curve has to smoothly
interpolate smoothly go from one point
to one uh slope to another and so on and
so
that's you'll see in in illustration
programs things like that you'll
sometimes see that you can have you know
these control points and you're defining
curves you're defining essentially not
only what which points the the curve
goes through but also what its slope is
and that's sufficient to define these
cubic curves that i've been mentioning
and that's sufficient to draw out the
shapes of what end up in fonts
and so
so that's any any font consists of a
bunch of vector specifications of you
know you draw it with this curve you
draw it with this circle you draw it
with a straight line that's what a font
is now there's a little bit of cheating
that goes on so-called hints and fonts
which is if you're going to really show
that font as just a few pixels and that
was more important probably in the past
when computer displays were less high
resolution than they are today if you're
really going to go down to just a few
pixels well do you pick that pixel or
this pixel when you're when you're
drawing this line you know if you draw a
line let's say at 45 degrees on a
computer screen you might say pick a
pixel then go sort of you know if you're
if you're thinking of these pixels in a
grid you pick a pixel you pick a pixel
that's that's to the you know um
north
northeast of that one then to the
northeast and so on a diagonal and
there's but if you that that's fairly
straightforward to see which pixels you
pick but if you change the angle of that
line becomes more complicated to see
exactly which pixels you pick because
you might you always have to go up by by
a sort of a jump of one pixel um and so
you might be you know if the line is is
less uh less but you know less highly
sloped you would want to go oh let's go
along for three pixels then up one pixel
go along for two pixels up one pixel and
so on you have to kind of pick exactly
how to do that and that that's a key
piece of for example this process of
rasterization that's a key thing that
you have to do
in um uh in sort of a drawing a line on
a computer display is one of the sort of
the the sort of core things you have to
understand how to do to convert from
vector graphics to bitmap graphics so
actually i could kind of describe a
typical algorithm that's used
um to
uh so one thing you can do is you can
say well
what is how do you define a slope you
say for such and such a distance that
you go along in the sort of x direction
you're going to go up a certain amount
in the y direction
and so let's say it's it's you're going
up um uh m times
in the y direction what you go along in
the x direction
well then what you would do is a typical
algorithm says you go along in the x
direction and you're sort of
accumulating how much uh y
motion should you get so let's say it's
m times the distance in x
and every time that m times the distance
in x becomes bigger than one
um
relative to you know you're restarting
it again every time it comes bigger than
one then you go up one pixel and
otherwise you're going sort of
horizontally on the screen and that's an
algorithm for drawing a line at any
angle on on a computer screen
okay so anyway you you you know when you
actually draw fonts you end up with
these these hints for drawing very small
fonts
um now where was i how was that how did
i even get to this i was talking about
um that's that's one of the
characteristic things reasons for which
you want to use vector graphics
is
is to be able to deal with fonts so you
can have the same description of the a
at a 12 point point on a 72 point point
font it's just the same font
specification it's just magnified in one
case relative to the other
so that's kind of the the way that
displays get get produced there now
things get there many many
complexities to all of this
for example let's say you have your
printing on a page black and white
and you want to print a grayscale you
want to print something great how do you
do it well the answer is you have to
make it out of dots
and you'll typically uh while printing
is and screens are a little bit
different in printing what you can do is
you can just have the dots
get progressively bigger so eventually
the dots will all run into each other
and will be pure black and if the if the
thing is supposed to be very white the
dots will be you know very small and you
can represent different gray scales by
just having a different size of dots so
you might have an array of dots and the
dots will be each dot will be a
different printed size on a computer
display you don't get to do that because
all the dots are the same size and so
you have to do a process that's called
dithering um and in dithering what you
do is you say well which pixels should
you turn on to get this gray level so
for example let's say you want half 50
gray then what you might do there is
just to turn on every other pixel so you
essentially get a checker board now you
ask the question if you want to get a
gray level of i know 0.37 or something
exactly which pixels do you turn on to
get that you have to be a little bit
careful because
if you turn on pixels
in
uh with
in the wrong kind of way you'll end up
seeing visually this kind of large scale
structure in what was supposed to be
gray you'll see these big waves of oh it
was a bit blacker in this area a bit
whiter in this area and so on and so
it's kind of a
there are a bunch of algorithms to just
decide to do that now when you've got
something like a photograph its gray
level is continuously varying and you
have to decide how do you switch on the
pixels to determine um
what um uh
if it's just black and white which
pixels do you switch on and there's an
algorithm it's a little bit like that
line drawing algorithm they mentioned
earlier basically what you do is you say
you scan the picture just from you scan
one line of the picture then the next
line the next line the next line and
what you do is you are as you scan it
you are
uh let's see you're continuously looking
at sort of the accumulated gray level
and you're saying every time the
accumulated gray level is greater than
some value emitter black pixel and
that's sort of how you're determining
how to put um uh how to put black into
into the picture and by the way you see
various kinds of weird little artifacts
of the stithering process if you look in
detail at pictures um
rendered on on a computer screen and for
example grayscale pictures rendered in
black and white
and and there's a similar approach by
the way that's used for color um same
same kind of idea of of taking you know
a continuous variation of color and then
rendering it um so for example you take
a picture an image and you rescale the
image there's a question of how do you
determine
um if the image had
at some large scale had a thousand
pixels across but you're going to put it
into a 100 pixel size region
how do you decide what um which pixels
to turn on which pixels to make uh which
color and so on how does that work and
it's a little bit easier on computer
screens these days because you end up
with printing as either a dot of ink
there or there isn't a dotted link
although it might be a different size of
dot of ink and so on but on computer
screens you can usually change the
intensity of the red green and blue as
well as deciding is it is it on or off
so anyway that was a little bit of an
introduction to
vector graphics versus bitmap graphics
rasterization is this process of going
from
the sort of description in terms of
symbolic graphics primitives to this
array of pixels this rasterized bitmap
form
um the thing that gets more complicated
is when you're doing 3d graphics
and you have to decide so in in 3d
graphics the biggest issue is hidden
surface elimination so if you've got an
object and let's say it's a a sphere or
something like this
um the you know the sphere you look at a
sphere well it's got the front face of
the sphere or a queue let's say you've
got the front face of the cube and
you've got the back face of the cube but
when you look at a physical material
cube then you don't see the back face
when you look at it from one side and so
but in the computer graphics
representation it's like well you've got
this geometry that represents the front
of the queue you got the geometry that
represents the back of the cube how do
you make that sort of physical thing of
you can see the front but not the back
of the cube and so a common algorithm
that was used is sort of a bit mappy
type algorithm is called the z buffer
where basically what happens is you say
well let's first of all you imagine how
would you project that that
three-dimensional cube the geometry of
the three-dimensional cube into a
two-dimensional plane and so that
involves perspective transformations and
things like that but basically you can
know where every piece of that if you
were drawing that 3d cube where would
you put the you know where would you
draw with your pencil to represent each
piece of the cube so you know where it
is in the two-dimensional plane
and then you simply asked well how deep
that that piece of cube that ends up at
this position on your screen
how deep would that be was that on the
cube that's the z value of where it was
on the cube and you simply start from
the back you start from the things which
were furthest away um and you simply
start drawing things uh starting from
the the ones furthest away to the ones
closest and so the ones that are closer
will overwrite the ones that are further
away and so you'll see just the front
face of the cube and not the back face
of the cube so that's sort of the
simplest approach to hidden surface
elimination um and it's one that's
used in many places the the disadvantage
of that approach
is that it's resolution dependence so if
you
this question about what scene what's
not seen you just are looking at every
pixel and you're saying is that pixel
one that will be seen or not seen but so
sometimes what you want to do in fact
this is something we kind of uh did very
early in in first versions of
mathematical morphing language back in
1987 1988
um is resolution independent hidden
surface elimination in which what you're
doing is you're saying well here's this
geometry here's this triangle for
example typically surfaces are broken
down into triangles um little tiny
triangles and you're asking given this
set of triangles which triangle will be
in front of each other triangle and it's
a messy complicated piece of math and
geometry to figure that out but when you
think of one triangle in front of
another triangle it's kind of going to
obscure a part of the triangle it's
going to break the other triangle into
little shards of smaller triangles and
so on and that's what you have to figure
out to do resolution independent hidden
services elimination which is something
that that we've done for a long time in
waltham language
all right that was a long answer to um i
think there was a question part of the
question here had to do with
human visual perception
and um
the fact that you know our retinas if
you look at our retinal erasanas cells
on the back of our eye that sense light
you'll find that they're arranged in a
hexagonal pattern
it's kind of just because there are sort
of more or less circular kinds of
photoreceptors
and you just smoosh them all together
it's like you have a bunch of coins and
you smush them all together and they'll
arrange themselves to be in a hexagonal
kind of beehive shape type arrangement
and that's why the cones aren't the the
photoreceptors on the back of our eyes
are also arranged more or less that way
and so uh we sort of start off with um
with this array of pixels um but very
quickly in our visual system we're kind
of uh they're across connections and
things that make our perception
uh not be in this kind of pixelated form
now if you're a
uh
if you're a
house a fly or a bee or an insect of
some kind
uh your eyes work differently than ours
but sort of the original innovation of
the trilobites back in the cambrian
period um you know 100 million whatever
it was 200 million years ago um that
their big innovation was was eyes
and if you look at a fossil i have one
on my shelf here actually um a fossil of
a of a trilobite you look at its eyes
there are a bunch of hexagonal pieces in
the eyes
those are what exist even in modern
insects and so on those are so called
amitya
um those are eyes where each little each
little segment of the eye as revealed to
the outside world is a separately a
separate photoreceptor so it's like you
have instead of it being an eye like
ours where all the sort of light
processing is happening centrally with
going through the eye lens and so on and
then the then it's falling on this
retina at the back of the eye instead
you have a different actual sort of
piece of eye at all the different angles
and you put together lots of pieces of
eye and so what you see is this sort of
well i don't know what you see because
i'm you know i'm not a trilobite or an
insect so it's hard to get inside its
brain so to speak to understand quotes
what it sees
um but uh at least what comes to its
brain is these much more discreet much
larger pixels you know we might have 10
million uh pixels effectively in our
visual scene but um uh a um
uh you know a a house fly might have
only i don't know what it is a few
hundred pixels in its whole visual scene
so it's much more granular much much
more uh sort of uh uh discretized
version of visual scene and and how it
turns that that sort of discretized
version into what it sees
is an interesting kind of uh
philosophical psychological question i
mean you can say what is the effect of
what it sees and you know for example if
it sees some uh thing that it's chasing
it'll see oh it went it lit up that
pixel and that pixel then that pixel and
it and it has some way in its brain you
know it only has 50 000 neurons or
something we have uh about 100 billion
um but uh in its 50 000 neurons it's um
uh somewhere there is some little little
thing that's saying oh if you see this
pixel light up then this one then this
one oh that means something is moving so
go you know jump at it or jump away from
it or whatever else
um but you know getting an idea of of
what the fly actually sees
is is a is a question of more philosophy
and so on uh sort of get how do you get
inside another consciousness so to speak
is a whole separate issue
all right let me see
um
okay i noticed another question about
visual visual perception from parker
when i close my eyes and apply pressure
i see colored dynamic geometric patterns
why is this
you know it's an interesting question
and i have wondered about that
um
it
the basic reason i think
is that you're putting physical pressure
onto your optic nerve
and that by pushing your eyes you're
increasing fluid pressure in your
eyeball and that's um
uh that's
uh causing your optic nerve
to
have
uh to activate so to speak and it's
sending signals down your optic nerve to
your brain that is causing your brain to
say oh you're seeing things
now i have to say
um
it's one of these things i've been
meaning to research this for for
50 something years and i've never gotten
around to it but but you know when i do
that i'll typically see this this grid
of of gray and gray and black squares
but the grid is somewhat distorted it's
not as if it's on a perfect sphere it's
some uh it's it's a distorted grid and
um but not very distorted and i don't
know why there's this grid i don't know
why there's a a grid of gray and black
squares and i don't think everybody sees
the same thing so you know the fact that
it's so pixelated and rectangularly
pixelated it's just really weird to me
and i don't know why that happens and i
have wondered whether the deformation is
related to the sort of the defamation
you know i wear glasses so you can tell
that my vision isn't perfect is the
defamation of them
uh
of of the of sort of light coming into
my eyes so so typically you know
what does one uh why does one wear
glasses well they're very usually it's
because the optics of one's eyes
isn't
isn't sort of perfect
and um there are typically a couple of
different things that happen i mean one
is near-sightedness long-sightedness
those are what happens there is the
light coming from
the outside world has to be has to be
focused by your eye lens into a spot on
your retina
and if the um in the case where
your your your eye lens is not strong
enough to focus so something that's very
close up if you want to get the light
from that to sort of reconverge and
focus on a spot your eye lens has to be
really thickened up and it has to be um
uh it has to um uh be deflecting the
light so that you you focus it to a
point
and so you can end up not being able to
see things not being able to focus
things on things close up when your eye
lens cannot be squashed enough to make
it thick enough to deflect the light to
get to your to focus on your retina and
those of us who get more ancient um
that's a common uh a common phenomenon
is that the eye lens gets more harder to
squash that so in the eye lens it's kind
of a clever setup um the lens in your
eye
an ordinary lens made of glass for
example it's a fixed lens it has a
certain thickness it will uh focus light
to a certain amount
but your eye lens
is
is made of sort of squishy stuff and it
has it has some muscles around it the
so-called ciliary muscles that are
around it and
when you want to focus up close those
muscles squash the lens to make it
thicker and when you're focusing further
away those muscles relax and the lens is
flatter and so it's focusing light
coming from further away so when you get
more ancient um that eye lens and with
the eye lens tends to get less flexible
and the muscles i think get weaker and
so you're less able to to squash that
lens up to make it make it really thick
and so that means
it becomes more and more difficult to
focus on things that are close up that
that's something often happens with age
then the other thing that can happen is
when it's a question of seeing things
from very far away you can have uh
something where your eye lens is never
quite sort of flat enough to do that or
your eyeball is uh is it too long or too
short i have to think about that to that
the the thing can focus light properly
on your retina and that's uh that's if
you are um
if you're nearsighted that means that
you can't focus on things further away
and you can put a corrective lens in
your glasses that will successfully
focus the light for you um well if
you're doing it uh for near-sightedness
it will it will do more to bend the
light if you're doing it for
for long
for for sorry if you're doing it for for
things you can't see up close
um you want to focus the light more you
want to have a sort of a thicker lens
from things where you're dealing with
things that you can't see far away you
want to have a lens that is a diverging
lens um that will uh make the light
focus sort of on your retina rather than
kind of behind your asana where
where
not not successfully focused by the time
it gets to your retina
so in any case those are those are the
sort of the most simplest and most
common forms of of um
uh vision defects
are they're just the overall
um
uh
overall focusing of light and that's a
spherical correction because you can
make it with a spherical lens a lens
that is is sort of the same all the way
around and it's just how thick is the
lens um and um that's so so if you look
at an eye prescription it'll say you
know od plus one or something it's um
the d is it's latin dexter and sinister
for right eye and left eye um od and os
and um uh the um um
let's see which way round is it those
those numbers are numbers and diopters
which are a way of of specifying the
focal length of lenses um or the or the
magnifying power effectively of lenses
and so a typical kind of big correction
you know like we really need you know
you really need glasses is like three or
four or something like that um in the in
the well you should get glasses but
whatever it's like one diopter or half a
diopter or something of this kind
so the most common type of of correction
is these spherical corrections where
you're where you're just looking at um
um
uh we're just a question whether the
light focuses or not the next level is
so-called astigmatism
where the light instead of the your eye
behaving like an ordinary lens that's
sort of symmetrical all the way around
your eye behaves more like a cylindrical
lens
where it focuses light in one direction
but doesn't focus it in the other
direction the most common cause of that
is the cornea of your eye is not uh
perfectly uniform in depth and instead
has sort of bumps on it and that um and
that causes the light to be deflected as
it comes into your eye and so you get
this astigmatism where the light is not
focusing where where what was a point of
light uh
coming into your eye doesn't focus on a
point on your retina it focuses uh on
but it isn't quite focused it's more
like a line but it doesn't really focus
at all um and so that's that's
astigmatism and you can correct that by
using a cylindrical lens um and so you
typically have a a part of your your
correction that will be the spherical
part that's just the overall
magnification and then the cylindrical
part which is a magnification but for
something where the lens has is like a
cylinder and it'll give the the amount
of the the the magnification and then
the axis of the cylinder
um and so that's that's sort of the next
level of correction
for for eyes is um um
is this uh uh
is that astigmatic correction which is
this uh correction typically for sort of
bumpiness on the cornea and i know
because i'm an obsessive data person i i
got some imaging down at my cornea and
you can kind of see the it isn't it
isn't perfectly cylindrical or anything
it's it's just got bumpiness on it um
and uh that bumpiness is more or less
corrected by using uh glasses which have
lenses that have this little cylindrical
piece to them
um and uh you know if you do for example
lasik surgery um
what you're doing there is you're kind
of uh
peeling up your your you're burning off
uh a few layers of of um of cells in
your cornea to try and flatten out
typically um what uh uh what what the
cornea which is the
outer transparent outer coating of your
eye what that's like
and by the way if you really get
obsessive you can you can do higher
order corrections
to um uh in addition to spherical
correction cylindrical corrections you
can do higher order corrections and
people sometimes think about that um in
doing lasik surgery for example um and
uh if you're really obsessive you can
you can start imagining grinding glasses
where you have these higher order
corrections it's not actually clear
there are ways that the light can be
deformed coming into your eye that are
not correctable by lenses i mean that
you can get a good approximation which
is what actual glasses typically do but
you can't get it precisely right
and and for those of us who are ancient
um the typical thing is because our eye
lenses are not as flexible it's it's not
as easy to go from focusing on something
really close up to focusing on something
really far away um and so what tends to
happen is this trick i think benjamin
franklin is usually uh this trick is
usually attributed to him
of bifocal glasses or now progressive
glasses um and so bifocal glasses used
to have this trick that things in the
upper part of the glasses would be
suitable for looking at things far away
and things on the lower part of the
glasses would be lenses that were
suitable for looking at things close up
now what's been done more recently is
that glasses are progressive so if i tip
my head i have progressed slightly
progressive glasses at least um and uh
so you know when i'm looking down
that's some uh you know the things i'm
seeing my glasses are optimized for
seeing things well for the top part is
optimized for seeing things a bit at a
distance the bottom part is optimized
for things that i might sort of hold up
to
you know to read a book or or something
like that um and it's optimized for a
different distance and there's a lot of
sort of fanciness to figuring out how
you make a progressive changing of lens
and typically that's done by changing
the kind of plastic or whatever that is
changing the amount that it
refracts light
from one part of the glasses to the
other that's the way that you have
you make glasses that have that that
change and there's a lot of other
trickiness for example just the
mathematics of where you have glasses
that refract in this way versus that way
it's not easy to set that up correctly
and you end up having to deal with the
issue that that if you look
uh there's there's another parameter
which is how much to the side you look
and how much the glasses correct and
different sides and different people
have
when they read things some people when
they read they turn their head as they
read from one side of a line to the
other and other people move their eyes
and depending on whether you move your
eyes your head that determines whether
you're still looking through the same
part of your glasses whether you're
looking for through a different part of
your glasses um in uh when you're
reading across that line of text so for
example if you're reading a newspaper
which has just columns of text well
maybe nobody reads paper in physical
form anymore i i know i don't um but uh
magazines in physical form which have
columns of text those columns of text
are comparably narrow and so you're not
going to be you know turning your head
to a big angle as you move them but if
you have a book that has much wider text
measure then you might do that and then
it's a it's a whole tricky optimization
of glasses of how much you allow these
sort of changing refractive index versus
how much it changes as you look off axis
in one direction or the other um and
that's that's a whole tricky thing about
some uh so-called channel width it's
usually called um i mean i might say
that by the way we were talking about
fonts and things like that
um there's a lot of trickiness in making
things be easy to read
for example if you have a long line of
text
it's it's usually quite hard to read
across that it's too wide and that's why
people tend to break it up into columns
because it makes it easier to read the
text
and and of course there are different
ways when you read there are very
different ways to read i mean there's
some people where if you change the
innards of a word they'll barely notice
and they'll still think it's the same
word i'm like that um whereas there are
others where it really matters you know
it's sort of letter to the letter letter
and it's it's reflected in people's ways
of learning to read this kind of
sounding out things versus whole word
reading and
learning and so on and i think there
there's pretty good evidence that the
really the details of kind of the way
fonts are formed and things like that
has an effect on how people can sort of
in you know how quickly and how easily
people can sort of recognize oh that's
that word that's that word and so on and
and for example for people who are
dyslexic there's a whole other set of
issues to do with uh
not sort of you know flipping the
letters around as you think about them
and so on and there seems to be some
evidence that things like the way these
fonts work and so on can have an effect
on the extent to which you can you can
sort of get things and know what order
they're in and such like
oh boy um
i've been yakking on about about eyes a
lot
um
uh
richard is saying he sees this grid also
um
i don't know why you see squares i mean
this is such a crazy thing because
there's nothing square about your eyes
your eyes if they have anything the the
um the photoreceptors are in hexagonal
grids i just don't know where the spurs
come from i really want to know that now
i'm i'm um it's terrible that um
uh i've literally been been sort of
meaning to figure that out in for since
forever i mean one thing of this i did
figure out when i was a kid which is if
you take a black and white disc
and you spin it and you particularly if
you have little trailing pieces of the
black and white on you know half black
half white disc you spin the disc you'll
see you'll see color um particularly if
you have little sort of uh tails of the
black and white you'll see rings of
color around where those are and i kind
of had a theory when i was a kid for how
that worked it turns out my theory is
more or less correct i think um my
theory was that the different uh red
green and blue color receptors in your
eyes
are kind of uh they have different rates
at which they kind of recover from
getting a red signal getting a green
signal getting a blue signal and so on
and because they have different rates
when you spin this disc
your you know the red one hasn't quite
recovered even though the blue one has
by the time the disc comes around and so
that means you still see red even though
you're not seeing blue and that mismatch
causes you not to just see
uh sort of the gray from the combination
of black and white it causes you to see
colors instead and i think that theory
is turns out to be more or less correct
but at the same time i was i was
probably 10 years old or something i was
trying to figure that out and i was
trying to figure out this this um gray
and black squares and i realized i don't
think i've well
i should have figured it out in all that
time but i haven't um
okay aaron is commenting about asking
about fresnel lenses
um
okay i can i'll talk briefly about that
uh
and talking about vr headsets and their
use of fresnel lenses
yeah okay so
so
the an ordinary lens
works by
okay so if you have
when light
enters glass
if you have a laser some light goes into
glass if it if you have a slab of glass
and the light is just going straight
into the slab of glass it'll just go
straight through the slab of gas light
goes more slowly in glass about one and
a half times more slowly than it does in
air um but it'll just keep going
straight through if on the other hand
the light is coming at an angle as it
goes into the glass because of that
difference in speed it's a little bit
tricky to work out how this is you can
see it in terms of the wave fronts of
the light that the thing will go closer
to the axis than it was before so it
comes in at an angle and it goes
i'm getting this the right way around
yes i'm doing it the right way around
and it goes um and it'll go more more
close to the axis so if you if you bring
in light at an angle it'll get tend to
be at a less of an angle when it's
inside the glass
okay so that effect is used to make
ordinary lenses and when you have a lens
that's kind of bowing out
you can it means that when there are
rays that are off the axis that are
coming uh into that into that lens
they'll be uh refracted to be going uh
at an angle that's at a different angle
so they might be coming in straight and
then they're then they're uh go at a
different angle and the fact that you
have this lens that's that's coming uh
that's sort of uh
going tapering on both ends means that
on both sides both top and bottom so to
speak means that it will focus light
where they're parallel rays coming in it
will focus them to come down to a point
and and similarly if you have instead of
the lens being a converging lens which
blows out you have it uh sort of you
have it to kind of um uh
have it not
not form something where it's going out
in the middle but goes out at the edges
then it will make the light rays diverge
okay so that's the ordinary way a lens
works
now
if you want to make a flat lens
let's say you want to make a lens that's
just flat
then you can do that the so-called
fresnel lens makes it has a bunch of
ridges
and those ridges each have it's just
another kind of way of arranging that
when you sort of hit a ridge then you'll
have the same effect of the light um
converging or diverging but instead of
it being sort of the whole thing is set
up in a um
uh in this the soul sort of uh uh you
know the whole lens works that way you
have it in a series of ridges um on on a
flat sheet
and that's a convenient thing to do for
all sorts of purposes when you make
different kinds of things and i guess
um
it was something that was used for
lighthouses back in the day
and
i'm trying to remember actually what's
the reason
for it in lighthouses was
um i think those kinds of lenses i mean
they're very much more you know that
they're more convenient like you can
have a sheet of plastic that is a lens i
i have many of these which is a fresnel
lens where it's just a sheet of plastic
it's not something that kind of bows out
in the middle so that that's sort of a
convenient setup
um
okay i think
uh
let's see i think i have to go very soon
here um maybe let's see if there's one
other
question
that um
um
there's a question from eddie about
visual perception i think we've been
we've been on a visual perception kick
today um about whether visual perception
is discreet or continuous i think i
talked about that actually maybe the
last time or the time before about
actually you know seeing packets of
light in our eyes
um
the
visual perception is is um i mean we
tend to make everything seem continuous
but it's interesting question whether
there are kind of optical illusions that
uh depend on the fact that ultimately we
have discrete photoreceptors and so on i
mean there are plenty of uh you know
what we tend to see in optical illusions
is
we tend to always extrapolate oh even
though this line wasn't there enough of
the rest of the line is there that we're
just gonna fill it in so a typical
version of this is if you cover one eye
um and uh let's see cover which way
around would it be
that one yes um
cover an eye
and um
you
have a some graph paper just paper with
a bunch of squares on it
and um you put a big black dot
on on those squares
okay and you look at these squares you
cover one eye and you focus on it
different distances away
then there'll come a point at which the
black dot will simply disappear and and
the reason that happens is because your
eye
our eyes um have some many design
defects but one of them is that the
optic nerve
is
is uh uh
um it the place on your eye where the
optic nerve connects is a place where
you don't have photoreceptors and so
it's a place where you can't see
anything in that eye of course you've
got two eyes so that part of your visual
field is covered by the other eye um but
if you force yourself to be looking
through one eye then there'll be a
there'll be a place an angle at which
there just aren't any photoreceptors so
you can't see anything at that angle
from that eye now if you're looking at
this piece of graph paper and you know
you see this graph paper and you're
filling in it's got you know it's got
all these all these crisscross lines on
it
and then that place where you actually
can't see anything because where your
optic nerve is and there are no
photoreceptors um the black dot is right
there well you don't see the black dot
isn't that incredibly weird because
what's happening is your brain is saying
look i know what's going on in this
piece of paper it's got a bunch of you
know vertical and horizontal lines
that's just what this piece of paper
must be like let's just fill that in
everywhere
uh you know we don't know what we don't
know specifically from our eyes what the
piece of paper looks like in this
position but look we'll just assume it
goes on the way it was before and that's
what our brain perceives even though if
you you know look at a different
distance or you uncover your other eye
it's like oh my gosh there's a black dot
there but that is something which our
brain does not perceive yet our brain
fills in things it doesn't say missing
data here you know we don't know what's
here instead it just interpolates what
it sees elsewhere on the piece of paper
and just fills it in and so that's
that's an example of one kind of optical
illusion but but they're they're just an
awful lot of them where where one is
just sort of making assumptions one's
brain is kind of making assumptions
based on sort of ambient things that are
there i'll give you one other example
it's another slightly tricky tricky one
which which i've certainly encountered a
bunch of times
which is uh what color something is what
color something appears to be depends on
what other colors there are nearby
so for example our our color vision
system
tends to sort of auto correct for the
ambient color
so for example if you say this thing is
blue okay let's look at it under a
different kind of light let's look at it
under a much
you know yellower light like say an
incandescent light bulb as compared to
the sun those have very different those
are very different uh color spectrums
and so they
but it is a fact that that we tend to
still perceive oh that looks blue both
in bright sunlight and under an
incandescent lamp and in different
settings with fluorescent lights and
things like this which which according
to if we actually looked at the
frequencies of light coming from that
thing that we said was blue they'd be
very different in those different cases
but our eyes say it's blue in all those
cases and so what's happening is that we
are correcting for the ambient color
we're looking at oh what are the colors
of everything in the scene let's let's
know that that's the baseline and let's
say the thing we're actually looking at
that blue dot or whatever um you know it
is blue relative to everything else it
is very blue relative to everything else
in the scene
okay so that that leads to so there's a
lot of questions about how large scale
that correction is so for example if
you're looking at an image and you see
on your computer screen
you see something where there's mostly
yellow and there's a blue dot in the
middle where it's mostly red and there's
the same color blue in the middle but it
will not look the same
and and that's um and and that happens
on quite small scales in our visual
field and so for example if you are
making you know things i've often done
of making uh
pictures of the effects of simple
programs like cellular automata we've
got a bunch of different uh
cells and there are maybe four or five
different kinds of cells you say oh i'm
gonna represent those in different
colors one's red one's green one's
whatever else
you say and then you look at these
pictures and you're like oh my gosh
there are not just four colors here
there are lots more colors why is that
well it's because of this color
perception thing that something which
was supposed to be just red on a
different background looks a color other
than red so that that's a tricky thing
and i i wondered years ago whether it's
possible to correct for that whether it
would be possible to sort of make it
more red than it would otherwise be
and so that
even though it had a blue around it it
would still seem the same red as the big
block of red which didn't have blue
around it
at the time i didn't figure out how to
do that i'm not sure if it's possible it
may be that if you sort of make the
colors more muted in general you can
still successfully do that
all right i should uh um
better get going here i might have to go
back to my day job but thank you for
those uh
interesting questions and um hey
somebody figure out that thing about the
um rubbing your eyes and and uh and and
the grid of squares
um
it's uh
you know the the
the thing that would be very curious if
if it's squares because we see so many
squares in our environment i don't think
so because i know i was seeing these
things well since i was a young kid but
i guess i'd already seen lots of squares
in my environment by the time i was you
know five years old or something
um all right we should wrap up here
thanks very much and see you now